hey what's up welcome to winners on a
wednesday my name is samuel leagues i'm
a property investor and i
train and help hundreds and thousands of
other people to become
property investors and on this week's
winner on a wednesday i have
and cherry she's a pub owner and she's
been doing that for almost a decade now
and now she's transitioning into
becoming a property investor and
entrepreneur so and
welcome to winners on a wednesday how
are you doing i'm good thank you thank
you
so you've been um you've been really
successful what's the name of your pup
the broomfield tavern in coventry
broomfield tavern and it's like an
award-winning pub
i have loads of really really good
reviews and
you've been doing that now for almost a
decade yeah frightening
how is it how is the pub business doing
right now it's dying
it's dying um so obviously before covid
um people were starting to find it quite
difficult my old boss when i worked in a
pub
said it's not like the 1980s where you
know it was a licence to print money
so now it's really a question of you
know you've got to think outside the box
you've got to find your niche
and that's what i did you've been saying
this since before the pandemic you've
been saying this for the last year or
two yeah you think that
the pub business is a dying business
yeah the government don't want it
no i mean you can when you can i
sometimes wonder when i go out for a
pint
um you you know and i'm i'm out of power
i'm just like trying to work out how
they're making money i mean
i mean it's it's tough you have been
adapting like crazy
yeah how have you been doing that what
have you been doing then we're going to
talk about what you're doing in property
okay so um so we we've won 16 awards in
the last nine years
um from the campaign for real ale um we
then uh extended our range from just not
ales
to ciders as well and we had the most
ciders in coventry from as many
different sort of cider producers as
possible which made it interesting
we then got people traveling from all
over the country to come to our
um to our pub and see it and so that was
really good
but um we found that um it's still very
very difficult to make money in the pub
trade now more than ever and obviously
then covert hit
um in the first lockdown we thought
right okay we're locking down today what
are we doing
to make money tomorrow so um in march um
we decided that we were going to do
takeaway so
i ordered in 200 odd cartons two pint
cartons a uh
from a a fabricator and he
they they delivered it and we we started
selling pints and both ales and cider so
people were really happy my customers
were over the moon
and we got lots and lots of people
saying thank you very much and then the
second lock down i said well my
competitors must be doing that so let's
let's take it a step up so then we
started doing a delivery
unfortunately my competitors didn't do
that which i don't understand so we're
still the only problem in the area
that's really selling
points um by the way what are they doing
then are they just
closed they're just closed there are a
few that are doing takeaway food
i think one does pizzas and one does
something else so
they're surviving on the food side of
things so you're the wet lead pubs
i don't know what they're doing so you
so you are really
adapting the best you possibly have
you're working hard
are you making profit no
we're keeping our head above water it's
paying a few bills
um but it's it's not what we used to
sell so you know it's
what's the future for the pub business
like when the pandemic finishes do you
think that it's gonna be booming again
i think it'll boom for a short time
afterwards when people sort of
yeah break out you know they're gonna
they're gonna leave the panda make it's
gonna be some immense freedom and
they're all gonna hit the pubs and the
clubs and whatever whatever's open i
mean uh
it's what really annoyed me was when
they
they
said um boris johnson announced and he
said oh
we're going to allow pubs to open over
this week of christmas and it's almost
just like
oh there's the carrot take it away yeah
i know but even then even when he said
we're going to do it i was just thinking
as if the problems are even going to
want to because it's like you know what
no you can't just use us now you close
now you're open then you close but then
they're changing the goal
it's the daft rules that went with it so
and i'm in my opinion
i'm not speaking on behalf of anybody
else but in my opinion they're the most
stupid rules going and i can talk about
it for hours
but i'll just simply say this you want
our pub to open
until 10 o'clock and then everybody has
to leave her bang on 10 o'clock or you
might get hit with a ten thousand pound
fine
okay the problem is 24 hour licensing
was brought in
so that people disperse at different
times now when it first started
everybody was standing outside the pub
and there were loads of them
and they were they were so close and you
thought well tell me that's not a recipe
for covid they're not going to catch it
in the pub but they're going to catch it
when they're outside because they're not
dispersing at different times
the other thing is that there was a
rumor you know um
i think it was scotland the pubs can
open but they can't serve alcohol what
would you like me to serve milkshakes
it's it you know the rules are so stupid
they're arbitrarily being created
but it doesn't seem like actually
anyone's thinking about it
yeah and i think the pub trade is going
to be hit so hard the amount of pubs
that were closing before covid
now it's going to be astronomical so you
just thought forget this i'm joining
samuel leeds academy absolutely
absolutely so you joined the academy
what
how did you enter into the world of
property investment i know you were
probably
you bought the pub 2011. no i bought it
2014.
um and uh we did okay from it we were
pulling a rent from it and we were happy
with that
um i used to flip properties as a hobby
i used to live in them and turn them
over when i was
working full-time so i knew i was
comfortable with that and one of your
strategies
is brr and i love that strategy yeah but
when i joined the academy
my eyes were suddenly open to all the
other strategies that are out there and
things i'd never even heard of before
like
rent to rent where you can create
something out and nothing with none of
your own money i mean that that blew my
mind that was amazing
um so yeah i really and you've you've
done some interesting things which we'll
talk about over the last few months
where you basically set yourself up
financially for life
yes which is incredible yes um so
so you've i mean for a start talk to me
about what you're doing with the pub and
how you
have used the strategies in terms of
you know the development strategies and
talk to me about what you're doing
because it's incredible okay
so the pub's got a really really big
garden and it is still a little bit
derelict and run down so we're taking
we were before before covered we were
taking the money and we were slowly
renovating the pub but
people think oh you know why haven't you
just done it well the problem is it
takes a lot of money and time and when
you're open
15 hours a day you don't have the time
to do it and then of course it's late at
night you can't because your neighbours
are there
and obviously we're surrounded by a
residential area so when we came to um
thinking about it my partner and i were
talking obviously we weren't trading
for half the week because we weren't
doing the deliveries and takeaways and
we said well what can we do
and we kept coming back to our back
garden which used to be
um used for a long time ago it was used
as a court now it's just a garden
and it's a bit of a dumping ground and
we thought what a wasted space
right next to the city center what could
we do with it and my partner was genius
he came up with
why don't we develop it and and and i
thought you know it's so obvious
um but had i not done the academy i
wouldn't have thought outside the box
and said well how do we develop it
i just said yeah build a house whereas
now we're thinking
what's the maximum profit we can pull
from it so we decided we'd get planning
permission for
commercial units now i thought well how
do i go about getting planning
permission i've never done that before
so after um what we did on the academy i
thought you know what i'm just going to
phone a couple of architects and find
out
and the first architect was brilliant
told us what we could do came out viewed
the property
did a few sketches and before we knew it
yeah we've got planning permission for
five community commercial units on our
on our back garden that is
incredible and not only are you going to
be able to
um you know obviously add value to the
to the pub doing that
but that's going to give you an extra
revenue rental income yeah how much how
much
how much revenue will that produce each
month cash flow profit
cash flow profit we're looking about two
to two and a half grand that's
incredible
well chef with it yeah very much so i
mean that's that's you know it might not
sound like a great deal
but that's they're small units and
it's it's a dish in addition to the pub
so um
it basically helps the pub if the pub
still struggles we've still got money
coming in
if we come out of the lockdown we've
still got money coming in so it's
looking
you know it's really good for the pub
either way because it's on the pubs
you know land so yeah but you've also
been going like crazy doing other stuff
you've
just bought a property in please
thoughts
tell me about the story how you found it
what the situations of that because
that's an incredible deal
so um i was looking and i was really
pumped after the academy
my first couple of courses and i was
looking all over the country and then i
decided on grimsby i didn't like grimsby
um so i moved to cleethorpes which is
it's got an award-winning beach
um and it's just it's really nice little
town so i started looking checking the
figures making sure it works
and found that actually it works for
rental it works for quite a lot of
things and i found a property there
um that has two flats it's been split
into two flats but it wasn't done
properly so
i decided to talk to my partner and just
go for it so
um we've we've pretty much bought it now
and we're just waiting for completion
and uh we're going to title split it now
it was originally
going to be a brr project um and when i
looked at the property it'd been on the
market for 19 months and i said to the
estate agent right i'm going to book a
viewing
yeah and i looked at the photos and i
thought i can see what it hasn't sold
the photos it looks a bit dingy i went
to see it yeah
you're like does it smell does it smell
yeah
it looks just you look like this
disgusting property right yeah
um and it's like you say on the academy
you know there's loads of landlords
there that are actually quite amateur
even though they've got a lot of
properties they're quite amateurish
about it
and it turned out that the landlord had
refurbed the property new carpets
painted the walls new kitchens but he'd
never updated the photos
so when you've got these on either side
of selling for 86 and 90 grand and i've
picked this property up for 76.
so why on earth would the owner not
update the pictures that's crazy
it's mental i don't know why so his
property's not selling nope
and he's thinking oh i might have to
stop the price no you have to change the
picture change pictures yeah so you pick
that up for 76 000 pounds yes
it's already in good condition it's in
good condition with that you can just
title split that so i'm going to title
it so the landlord no disrespect to the
landlord but he's been doing it all
wrong he's got the wrong pictures
he's he's he's failed to title split it
properly yeah
so he's basically just made a mess of it
you're gonna come along with your
or your knowledge you're going to buy it
cheap
you get a title splitter into how many
flats two two flats
how many bedrooms are that the top one's
one bedroom the bottom one's two
bedrooms
okay um but it's already operating it's
already operating what are the councils
saying about planning permission
so when i phoned up the council before i
put my offer in i asked um
what the likelihood is of getting
planning permission and they had to go
back to their microfiche because
it had been made into flats about 40
years ago
planning permission um had been applied
for but he'd only satisfied one of the
conditions
so they said i'd have to retrospectively
apply for planning permission again
um so the likelihood is it's going to be
awarded hands down but obviously it will
take a little bit of time i've got to
get all the
site plans and everything done i might
have to put soundproofing in but we're
not sure until
it comes to it but essentially yeah um
he just hadn't he hadn't finished the
process
he just started taking the rent which is
fine but then when he wants to sell it
which is now
cash buyers only you can't mortgage it
so that's where i come in
so you're gonna with a small amount of
money significantly
push the valuer yes and then and then
the plan is then to refinance it and
pull pull your money back out yes
and just and just keep going yes
incredible recycle my cash
yeah recycle your cash which again will
bring you all as well
obviously you've got an asset but then
also you're going to be getting an
income stream two flats from that as
well
yeah so i mean how does it feel now then
to be you're effectively full-time in
property now i am a full-time property
investor how does it feel
awesome yeah genuinely awesome and i
could have tried it on my own but
i think i would have at some point it
would have really smacked me in the face
like it did with that landlord you know
he should have known better he should
have done better
and i think the the most important thing
whatever you decide to do is knowledge
you know um whether it's property with
the academy or whether
i don't know if you want to want to run
a cake shop you've got to know how to
make cakes you know
you've got to have the knowledge and a
lot of people just think oh that sounds
good let's do that and they don't
actually go out and get the knowledge
um and you can't do anything without
knowing exactly what you're supposed to
be doing or
employing someone who does if you can't
yeah you know was it a tough decision
when you the publisher's publishers
isn't making great money
it's forking out the investment for the
full property investors academy
honestly it was heartbreaking i handed
the cash over and i thought have i done
the right thing
is it a scam have i done it right don't
know yeah
and you watched all the uh samuel lee's
exposed videos absolutely yeah
and you showed your partner and you were
working out yeah
what was going on in your head at this
point so what do you think when you
watch the
samuel leads exposed videos like oh god
did your heart sink a little bit
a little bit yeah after or before you
bought the academy it was before
right and then i watched a few more
after and i thought oh god have i done
the right thing it's a lot of money what
i've
done because being a publican you don't
have a lot of money you might have done
years ago but now
no and we we talked about it in depth
and my partner's
very supportive and he basically said
you know what if you feel in your gut
that it works and it's right then do it
and i thought my brain's telling me
perhaps slow down and my gut was saying
just do it
so i just went with just do it because
you know all through the academy you say
take action and i didn't take action
as much as i should have done and i now
uh a year down the line think
god i wish i'd been kicked at the
backside sooner because
genuinely it's only the ones that take
action that actually do anything
and you can have all the haters going oh
you know you haven't done this and
this is all rubbish and how could you
possibly do that it's great to have the
knowledge but if you don't actually
implement it you'll never get anywhere
anyway
i mean i've got a degree i haven't used
it if i use it great i could be
you know in a nine-to-five job in europe
somewhere earning lots of money but i
didn't do it because i thought well i
haven't
you know i haven't taken the action for
it so i did something else but generally
take the action
you will do something and and and you
know i'm a proof of that i didn't never
thought in a month sundays i'd be
sitting here in front of you
yeah so yeah and you've had your own
fair share of haters with your pub oh
wow yeah
oh wow yeah what's that been like
so um obviously you know as a as a
company owner who are lots of companies
um
it's it's kind of tough at the top and
you find that um whether it's a tiny
tiny company or a multi-million pound
company
people love to hate you love to hate you
and the better you do the more they want
to hate you
um but the thing is if they were as good
they would um
they would have their own haters and
they would achieve and and i think at
the end of the day
i think it's all it's all an attitude
and a mindset i'm prepared to be hated i
don't care
but i know that a lot of my customers
absolutely love what we do
they love our products um from obviously
from the pub side of things
and i think you can look at your ratings
they're incredible your rewards your
reviews
it's absolutely it's the best inclusion
i've taken customers home
because they've left their cars outside
because they've had one drink too many
and they think you know
better safe than sorry oh i don't know
if i'm going to catch the last bus and
i've actually taken them home in my car
because i would rather see my customers
home safe i don't know many pubs who
will do that with their customers yeah
and that's the thing it's the personal
touch and my customers are my family
they yes they put money in my pocket and
pay my bills and put food on the table
for me but at the same time they're the
ones writing the reviews and i think
it's that personal touch
we've gotten so used to like the chain
pubs and we've gotten so used to like
the big super stores and
that personal touch i think is missing
and people
value it certainly people my age and
older yeah oh you know
and and and with the academy i thought
i'm never going to meet samuel leeds and
then i met alastair
what a guy um i think he's he's my new
guy on a pedestal he's fabulous he he he
he just says it as it is and i
appreciate that more than sugar coating
i would rather know my failures and then
say right but you could do this better
than just say well well done for what
you've done and it's like well
yeah but it's not well done is it it's
rubbish i've done badly so i'd rather
that
but with a personal touch it is a
personal touch you'll slap you on the
back and say you know what well done
yeah wow yeah and and i appreciate that
more and i know a lot of people my age
and older
exactly they were brought up with that
and now this whole sort of
standoff thing that's what you get off
you go i i don't see that that's a
that's that's serving your customer
i just don't it's the same though i mean
we have our haters but if you actually
look at what
our customers are saying you're a
student you know
you see them you see the you know you
see you sit with them
and they're um not only they're happy
but they're also doing deals
yeah doing deals and the thing is i mean
i i spoke to
these um there's a few um students i met
who haven't done anything
and they've said you know oh well it
really didn't work for me well why
didn't it what did you do
well what do you mean what did i do well
what did you do what did you implement
oh nothing
if you do nothing then nothing's gonna
happen yeah you know and
um those coaching calls and mentoring
calls i didn't really take them to begin
with
and yet now it's like oh every week i
can phone and speak to a professional
who knows what he's talking about who
can advise me
do you know what you can't you can't go
wrong with that you've got advice on
hand
the other academy members are in all
walks of life there's one academy member
that i spoke to he's done so many deals
even before the academy
but he knows his stuff yeah and the
reason he's doing the academy is to
develop his strategy base
yeah you know so you've got even amongst
the academy members you've got people
that are so knowledgeable and that can
give you advice for free
yeah yeah and i think you know
ultimately everyone's on their own
journey you've got some people that
you know two three deals to them is
amazing and then other people they've
already done two or three days before i
joined the academy now they're doing 20
deals
and there's a massive diverse mix um but
what would you say has been the biggest
kind of like
breakthrough aha moment lesson that
you've learned over the last sort of six
12 months
i went on the business of property
investing yeah
and like i said alistair made us do an
exercise and there was a major light
bulb moment
when i sat there and
i realized that actually my bar staff
earned more than me
wow for the hours i do yeah and i just
thought what's going on there and he
made me
change my perspective on stuff um
which obviously i can apply to the pub
but i can also apply to the property
investing
and i've had quite a few light bulb
moments since i started the academy and
it just kind of smacks you in the face
because
at the back of your mind it's fairly
obvious and you know but you never
actually bring it to the front of your
mind and think i'm actually going to
implement it you just think oh yeah
it's just kind of oh probably but to
actually do the figures and sit there
and go
wow for the hours that my members of
staff do compared to the hours i do i
actually earn about 40p
less per hour minimum wage and i'm the
business owner and what's that about you
know
interesting it's it's thought-provoking
and i think a lot of this academy
a lot of it is new strategies that you
learn but a lot of it is actually
look at yourself what can you improve
and pull the best out of you
which is what the trainer's there for
they pull the best out of you yeah and
again it's not
you you've been mentioning other people
like alistair and all you other members
of the academy oh yeah yeah
fabulous not just me i mean i'm
obviously you you're the inspiration
and you're the one that sort of sets the
ball in motion yeah but then since i've
met all these other people it's made me
realize that actually there's a whole
world out there of people
yeah who can help you and support you
and they don't want anything for it they
don't care
yeah they're on their own journey that's
what it is it's a world that you get
introduced to
um and i mean as well when after you did
the crash course
you were out viewing houses and they
didn't quite work for you
no and you did nothing with them no and
then later on you realized
well so i did the crash course it was
super motivating i then joined the
academy
did my first academy course i was like
right i can do this
and i could the problem was i am
i still have that little voice talking
to me saying well are you sure you can
do it you sure it's not a scam
and i found all these deals and they
were way over 25 and i was thinking
that's a good deal
return on investment they were massive
deals and then i'd look at them
and i talked to my partner and then and
he'd say look you do what you think is
right i'll support you and i'd look at
them some more
and then i'd pick up the piece of paper
scrumple it and chuck it in the bin and
go well i don't want to look at darby
it's too far away
and then i pick up birmingham and go
it's a bit expensive and chuck it away
and as i realized after i'd done all the
code
sourcing and deal sourcing uh that
actually i threw thousands of pounds in
the bin that would actually have helped
me on my journey
faster so yeah don't take anything
lightly
yeah because it's like money down the
drain it really is it really was
everyone should be a deal saucer whether
you've got money you haven't whether you
you should be a deal source if you're in
property yeah um what's been your
favorite program did you did you like
the deal selling masterclass
i did i did that's a real eye opener and
it's great because it's interactive
and i've been on courses before and it's
like you like
you know you start but we get christmas
for dance you know the dancing
to be fair i've got to say when i first
came on the crash course and we started
clapping and dancing i was like this is
really american
yeah yeah um but then you explained that
actually it's been scientifically proven
to keep you a lot awake and because
they're really long courses i mean
um you know one of the courses i went on
was like eight o'clock in the morning
registration so you had to be awakened
with it from eight o'clock because
you're networking if you really wanna
work well you're networking
nine o'clock the course starts then you
finish at 10 at night how on earth do
you keep people awake all that time
and it works i was as sharp at 10
o'clock because i was at nine o'clock in
the morning yeah
yeah it really the way that we teach the
accelerated training and coaching that
we do
and people might take a snippet of like
30 seconds dancing on the stage or
clapping oh this is what it's like it's
like no
no no that's 30 seconds in between an
hour and a half of bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang content
to keep you like with it and ready you
know people miss it or try and find a
reason
um you know to discredit i think i'd say
if
if you're going to be a hater that's
entirely your choice
but actually find out about it don't
just take other people's word just find
out about it go on the crash course
yeah because if i hadn't done the
academy i'd have still been able to do
property i just wouldn't have had the
knowledge i've got now
yeah so and it's certainly the start
just you mean from the crash course cash
course
crash course alone that's true it's true
the crash course gives you all the all
the basic foundational everything
it does and then the academy we assist
you through it we give you the further
advanced training
what's your strongest reason for doing
this my son
my son and my son is growing up now in a
world that's going to be after covered
completely different now i didn't know
that at the time
but obviously now it's just a motivating
factor he's seven years old he's a
miracle baby
um because you know i was told at 18 i
couldn't have kids so i wouldn't have
taken a pub on if i'd known i could have
had a
child and so now it's building up his
future and making sure that i can retire
relatively early um and work when i want
to work rather than because i have to
so i can be with him and and my partner
can be with him and we can just have
a good lifestyle with him that's great
yeah and what what possessed you
to take on the pub in the first place
that's like a big mac
um so as much of a nutshell as i can
condense it into i never heard that
so um i was a debt collector and then i
went from debt collecting
uh people's houses it's not as bad as it
sounds because actually you don't want
to empty somebody's house if you can
work with them
so i was actually very good at that but
i realized i wasn't earning enough money
so then i went into debt collecting for
companies which you earn a lot more
money but it's so
boring and then it got to the point
where i thought you know what
i can't do this till i'm 70 80 years old
i just can't
so um i've always had a second job even
when i reach sort of supervisory
management level
i've always i've always worked in a pub
why drink in a pub
when you can get paid to socialize in a
pub and then drink afterwards
so i did that and so
all the way through i had a second job
and i thought what am i good at and i
thought well i'm good at property but i
don't know enough about it
and i'm good at pubs and i know about
that so i want to take a pub on and then
it was just about that time i met my
partner
and he was super supportive from day one
and i found the pub
the broomfield tavern took it on in 2011
just after the recession
and everybody said are you nuts are you
crazy leaving a good job to take on a
pub
that's been empty for like 13 months no
trade no niche market no nothing
you must be crazy and i thought do you
know what don't tell me i can't
do something when i know i can because
i'll prove you wrong and i did and my
partner and i worked
hard and we had some horrible moments we
had debt collectors at the door because
the pub wasn't earning enough money
um my dad died in 2014. it was it was a
horrific
year um but what came out of it is
the final nail in the coffin was when um
the area manager
for the brewery came to us and he said
look um i've got some bad news
so i thought well it can't get any worse
than my dad dying and he said
we're going to sell the pub because
you're the fifth landlord not to make us
money and we've got a policy that if
five tenants can't make money we sell
the asset
so i said well what's our options and he
basically said you can either pack your
gap but
pack your bags and be jobless and
homeless in the same
hour or you can buy the pub now
i had bad credit my partner had bad
credit we had no way of
of basically getting a loan so we
thought well we're
we're going to do it there's a light
there we're going to take it
um and we we basically um i was phoning
every financial company commercial
financial lending institution trying to
find
it find out if there was anybody who'd
lend us money one said yes we can
um they weren't worried about our credit
rating because it was commercial it was
based on the property
but they said it's going to take 12 12
maybe even 16 weeks to push the deal
through
and the pub company went no it's going
to go in auction in six weeks and we
were like how on earth are we going to
get that so we were talking about it we
were throwing
every idea we could at it we were trying
to find out how much we could borrow
from friends and family
and then one of my customers who will
always be a fairy godfather to us
came up to us one night and said i've
got that sit in my current account
couldn't help that over here and we were
like of course you have
you know go have another drink we'll see
another time you know he came back four
days later
he wanted to speak to our solicitor our
bookkeeper he had the money he lent it
to us over 10 years
that was in 2014 and in um
october of this year which is six years
later not 10 we paid him off
so even during covered we managed to
just about pay him off so yeah we were
really chuffed really chuffed
you are a very special person get on
with it do it
get on with it and you bought the pub
for 176 000 in 2014. yes you've been
running it for three years
yeah and now it's worth how much
um conservatively about four hundred
thousand but you're about to now build
all these
communities yeah and push it
incredible you know what it's been such
a pleasure
just seeing you getting to know you
watching you
um blossom through your property journey
and um
i mean what would what would be your
final piece of advice because i know
you've you've had the skepticism you've
had a little voices you've had
you know someone's about everything
someone who's watching this it's just
thinking i'm not sure
can i really do this struggling to
believe in themselves struggling to
believe in the strategies or property
i mean what would be your strongest
piece of advice to them
even if you haven't got the confidence
um
and you know you're not a very confident
person just take the plunge
because the confidence comes and if you
do the further training with the academy
by god it comes in buckets absolute
buckets
you you become so much more confident
talking to people
i mean i'd never had a problem phoning
estate agents but there were some people
on the academy who were petrified of
picking the phone up
now they're calling them like it's you
know it's just a run of the mill thing
and and i think yeah the biggest thing
uh is is
do the action take the action you'll
develop the confidence
and everything kind of falls into place
and you can't see that now
a lot of people can't see that now i
couldn't see it now i thought well yeah
okay you say get the
get the deal and the money will come but
i don't see how that happens
it genuinely does because if you find a
deal that's worth it
you you then have well you know it's
going to work because it works on paper
you've done all your calculations well
then all it is
is phone a couple of brokers compare
what they offer
and then it starts rolling the ball
starts rolling and then
from there you then have made contacts
whether you've made only one or whether
you've made 21
contacts with the academy networking and
that way you have the contacts that they
might not be able to invest in you but
they might know someone who does
so the money does come afterwards and i
didn't believe that i was my biggest
part of the skepticism was i don't see
how i can just put an offer in
when i haven't got the money sitting
there do you know what it doesn't matter
put the offer in
the money does come brokers go out of
their way to help you because they need
a fee
and at the end of the day they know if
you're an investor then you're going to
send more business their way if they're
good
so that's so powerful i think you just
need a bit of faith sometimes
you do you need to stop listening to
this little voice because i listened to
that old voice before i took the pub on
and i
i should have taken that pub on years
ago in the boom time not in the
recession
so i knew what i was doing i should just
you know i should have taken my
my little hobby of property developing
while i was working full-time a lot
further back then
but we are where we are we are where we
are yeah and smashing it so
thank you so much thank you for sharing
the story folks i hope you're feeling
inspired
please do me a favor drop a nice comment
below for and she has absolutely
smashed it i'm really really proud of
her every single week
i keep doing this and i'm gonna keep
doing it as well this is a permanent
thing
every week i interview one of my success
students who have had their lives
changed through my property investment
training
so if you'd like to experience that
training for free come on to the crash
course
that's where it all starts i'll leave a
link in the description below
also if you want to hear more interviews
from people you can check out a whole
list there's over 100 of these
right here and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel over here
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
next time